if we take all these letters say for
example in the word algebra right and we
want to rearrange them in such a way
that it forms you know a different word
than algebra how many ways can we do
that using all of the letters right well
let's first count how many letters we
have we've got one two three four five
six seven letters now when you order
seven items you can use this formula n
factorial and what n factorial does is
it says like whatever this number is
like say for example if it was like
three factorial what you do is you take
that number three and then you multiply
down to one so three times two times one
that's six so what the six represents is
if you had three you know different
items right you know how many different
ways could you you know rearrange those
three different items you know such that
the order is important right so there
would be six different ways to do that
you can test that out with like the
letters ABC you can do ABC ACB bacb CAC
you know and so on right okay there's
six different ways
now with algebra there's seven letters
here right so that means that there's
going to be seven factorial ways of
rearranging these letters now if you
want to see in a more descriptive way so
you imagine writing it out like this see
one two three four five six seven
there's gonna be seven choices like if
you were to reach into a hat seven
different you know choices for picking
out that first letter once you pick out
that first letter how many are there
left to choose for the next letter in
the word there's going to be six right
and then five and then four and then
three and two and one that's the same as
what I've written here seven factorial
so it's another way to think about it
the only problem is though is so you see
how it says distinguishable that means
that you know they look like they're
different if I just move this a over
here to this a over here like switch
these two A's it would still look like
the word algebra so what we have to do
is we have to see if there's any
repeated letters here you can see
there's two A's that are repeated so I'm
going to divide by 2 factorial 2
factorial is just 2 times 1 that means
there's two different ways of arranging
these A's ok so you know such that you
know it wouldn't really look like a
different word so we have to divide out
those multiplicities if you will so here
we're just going to go ahead and
simplify so 7 factorial we've already
written that out divided by 2 factorial
which is 2 times 1 and you can see that
- and the
those are gonna cancel so we really just
have to multiply 7 times 6 times 5 times
4 times 3 so let's go ahead and do that
C times 5 times 4 times 3 which is 2520
different ways of using all the letters
in algebra to make a different
distinguishable permutation which is
like an ordering of those letters right
so let's go ahead and do number 2 see
they can do this one we've got the word
pepper
okay so pepper let's see this one has
six letters so that means there's going
to be six factorial ways of arranging
six of those you know ladders the only
issue is we've got three P's and two E's
right so we have to divide out those
multiplicity so we're dividing out the
three factorial for the peas and we're
dividing out the two factorial that's
for the EES now again the three peas
that's three factorial that's three
times two times one which is six
there's actually six different ways to
rearrange these peas so that they're
actually like in the same it would look
like the same word it would look like
pepper and even if you were to you know
rearrange the word again in such a way
that lets say wrote it backwards like
our e PPE P again you could rearrange
these you know three peas in six
different ways so what we have to do is
you have to divide all those
multiplicities because otherwise it's
gonna look like the same word we want it
to be a different word right so let's go
ahead and simplify this so six factorial
is 6 times 5 times 4 times 3 times 2
times 1 3 factorials 3 times 2 times 1
and 2 factorial is 2 times 1 now don't
make the mistake of you know multiplying
these together and seeing that 6
factorial that's a mistake
because then you would just get 1 and we
know there's more than one way to
rearrange those letters so let's see
what we've got here the 3 the 2 and the
1 cancel 2 goes into 4 twice 6 times 5
is 30 times 2 is 60 divided by 1 is just
going to be 60 so there's 60 different
ways